foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror doing another book review
so anybody that's been watching these
anybody that's been around here for any
length of time
knows that I'm a pretty big fan of Grady
Hendricks so I've actually read and
reviewed you know not all of his books
but like a good handful of them I did
the southern book club's guide to
slaying vampires My Best Friend's
exorcism and horror store like so far
and even though I didn't review it for
the series because it's non-fiction I
also read and very very highly recommend
his you just outstanding and also
visually beautiful uh 2017 book which is
called paperbacks from Hell the Twisted
history of 70s and 80s horror fiction
please get the print copy because it's
just gorgeous like I love the cover and
I love the layout of it it's really
really nice
so overall um I found Grady Hendricks ex
Grady hendricks's work I think has been
like the most consistently fun and like
entertaining of all the modern horror
authors that I've read and I realized
that not all horror authors are going
for fun and entertaining but I'm just
saying if you just want something that's
just like a fun that's just gonna be fun
immersive entertaining without being
like too heavy or Grim or but it also
like has gory stuff to it like Grady
Hendricks is your guy I mean he's just a
really really good at that
um so I mean basically I've got to a
point where I've just if it's him I'm
just like yeah I'm reading that like
I'll just pick it up because I know that
I'm gonna be in for a good time because
all of his stuff is good
so his 2021 novel which is called the
Final Girl support group uh is no
exception to this rule I found this on
my Kindle unlimited and I was very
excited because I'd been wanting to read
this one for a while now I kind of went
into it and like I said I didn't read
anything about it other than just the
tiny little sentence blurb like at the
beginning so I kind of like went into it
I think expecting more of a slasher type
narrative which would be you know given
the title
but I have to say that the story
actually like surprised me with how
intricately constructed it was like a
kind of like a takeoff of the slasher
thing
now like most of his other work it's
pretty high concept and it features like
some cool mixed media elements like you
know because you know like horror story
was you know looked like an Ikea catalog
and stuff like that uh this one actually
has
I you know I read the um the ebook but
if you have the print one I'm sure it
like looks a lot better but they did
kind of do it a little bit on the ebook
but it has like little inner inner
insertions of like supposedly real
excerpts from uh research papers like
police interviews magazine articles
stuff like that that are look like
they're kind of like clipped to the page
or whatever but I have to say that
that's cool but it's like the real meat
of this story is sort of I guess the
evolving mindset of the main character
who kind of grows more complex as The
Story Goes On Now I actually read that
this book has been optioned for a TV
series I don't know if it's ever gonna
you know get made or not because they
option A lot of things and never make
them
um and I am like kind of cautiously
excited about that because I think this
would actually make a good series now I
did see if you saw I did a review of the
film adaptation of Grady hendricks's
2016 novel my best friend's exorcism I
didn't love that movie I thought it was
trying too hard to go the PG-13 route
and kind of pulled its punches somewhat
but it was a pretty solid little movie
of overall that you know pretty like
partially captured the spirit of the
novel so I'm hoping that whoever does
final girl support group if they ever
get to it like the TV series I you know
I think it'll be good it has the
potential to be like really good because
this is a very cinematic uh concept also
as an aside
I also love this little bit of trivia
that I discovered so the audiobook
version of the Final Girl support group
was narrated by none other than Adrian
King the final girl from the first
Friday the 13th movie and that was like
a whole meta Synergy that just I just I
love geeky [__] like that it's like it
just it just warms the cockles of my
little horror and nerdy heart it really
did so the whole conceit of the Final
Girl support group
is that all of those iconic horror
slasher movies that we know and love you
know Texas Chainsaw Massacre My Bloody
Valentine and Silent Night blood daddy
deadly night Silent Night deadly night I
meant to say uh Nightmare on Elm Street
um scream Friday the 13th were
essentially all based on true stories
although their titles aren't mentioned
outright in the novel's universe and
it's actually not clear if those
specific movies exist because all of the
titles have been changed even though
it's very obvious like within the novel
like what movie is being referred to
like the events of 1984 the 1984 movie
Silent Night deadly night for example
are kind of repurposed as the backstory
of the main character and the movie made
about her in the novel is actually
called sleigh bells but it's obviously
that movie that he's talking about it's
also mentioned that one final girl whose
backstory is based on the events of
scream had a series of movies made about
her case that was called stab which of
course calls back to the movie within
the movie like you know in the movie
Scream you know they had a movie made
about them and the movie series was
called stab so that was like in so it's
like meta on top of meta also I have to
say that all the characters in the novel
are named after the actors who portrayed
the final girls in the movie movies that
the backstory is referred to so like I
said it's meta upon meta upon meta so
there's like a ton of other more obscure
slashers that are referenced like
throughout the story like it's other
than like all of that stuff like being
in there it's uh so it's a lot of fun
for horror nerds like me to kind of like
go through and like pick out all the
Easter eggs and like try to figure out
like what movie he's talking about and
stuff like that I mean all that's fun
and everything like that but the book is
not just like an exercise in geekery I
mean that stuff is just like the
delicious garnish on top of the bloody
roast I guess of the book
um but there's more going on than that
so the entire story is told from the
first person perspective of a woman
named Lynette Tarkington and she
survived the massacre of her entire
family back in 1984 in events that as I
previously mentioned mirrored Silent
Night deadly night
there's also a recurring theme by the
way that most of these final girls had
their respective attackers or somebody
like related to their attackers like
their brother or something like that
um return later and try to kill them
again like try to finish the job so that
would lead to their real life stories
having sequels just like a slasher movie
would so for a while in the novels
universe
following the slasher Heyday of the 70s
and 80s all of these women you know as
well as their attackers were like
celebrities for a long time but you know
now it's the modern era times moved on
and no one really cares all that much
about them anymore they do have like
some hardcore fans and things like that
but mostly you know time has moved on
the crimes were so long ago
so each of the final girls and there are
six of them really like Lynette Adrian
Heather Marilyn Danny and Julia
um they've actually been coping with the
lingering trauma of whatever happened to
them like in their own way and they all
still meet Faithfully for their support
group meetings
um I think every week and these meetings
are overseen by a sympathetic
psychiatrist named Dr Carol Elliott and
it seems like each of the women is kind
of clinging to the group for their own
reasons because they all kind of have
their own thing going on
now for her part Lynette the main
character the the POV character she's
kind of chosen to deal with her past by
basically like shutting everyone out of
her life like not trusting anybody
um the only thing that she has that she
cares about is a pepper plant that she
basically like treats like a person
which actually is funny because the
plant actually come be kind of becomes
like his own character like as The Story
Goes On uh the plant's name is actually
fine which is uh short for final plant
because she'd had like some plants
before they died and this is the one
that she's had for the longest and she
kind of like talks to him and like in
her head and you know thinks that he's
talking back to her and stuff like that
another thing that she's done is she has
become completely and obsessively aware
of her surroundings at all times uh in
order to keep herself safe she's like
obsessed with being safe you know what I
mean like she lives in this apartment
with a reinforced cage like right inside
the door and she has these real
elaborate varying routes she takes like
whenever she has to go out anywhere to
prevent herself from being followed
um she doesn't have any social media
like she has all these backup plans like
plan a plan B plan C like some of them
which involve like a car that have like
an unregistered car that nobody knows
about it's filled up with cash and guns
and stuff like that that she's stashed
in some parking garage that she thinks
anybody knows about and all this all
this other stuff so you know it's
obviously not an entirely healthy way to
live but it seems to be like the only
way that she knows how to get on with
things so the other women each kind of
have their own thing going on um you
know Heather she kind of turned to drugs
uh Marilyn married this role wealthy guy
and I think she started her own business
as well and she kind of lives the life
of this sort of high society matron you
know and she lives in this compound that
has like reinforced walls and security
guards and stuff like that
um Danny actually moved to this isolated
Ranch you know in order to spend time
with her wife who's dying of cancer and
so on
there's also another final girl that
really nobody likes to talk about uh
who's named Chrissy and they all see her
as a turncoat for reasons that become
clear as you kind of go on in the story
The Women's personalities are all like
vastly different
and whenever they meet for a support
group which they've actually been doing
for 16 years at this point like you know
when the story starts the whole session
usually just devolves into Petty
squabbling and some of the women are
even questioning why do we even still
need to come here like you know none of
us get along anymore and it's like if
the group was helping us at all it would
have done so by now and it's like maybe
we should just quit and then some of the
other ones like no we can't you know
what I mean because they're kind of like
depending on it and all that kind of
stuff so it's you know it's kind of this
whole turmoil like at the beginning of
the story where the group is just never
going all that well however at one
particular group meeting uh Adrian one
of the final girls is a no-show and
nobody can get hold of her to see what
exactly is going on now some of the
women aren't really concerned they're
like maybe she just got sick of this
[__] or whatever but Lynette uh you know
she has this heightened paranoia thing
going on and that suggests to her that
something terrible might have happened
and indeed uh she turns out to be 100
correct now as the story goes on it
starts to become clear and initially
only to Lynette that someone or
someone's is targeting all the final
girls for elimination for motives that
are not entirely obvious until like much
later and whoever this person or persons
is or are
they seem to know everything about each
of the final girls even information that
the women thought was like inaccessible
or they thought nobody knew you know
what I mean
so the bulk of the narrative which again
told from Lynette's POV is
the unfolding of this very intricate
conspiracy that is designed to like kind
of Wipe Out the final girls and also
details Lynette's sort of desperate
efforts to convince her fellow survivors
or fellow final girls that they are all
in danger even though they seem to
perceive that the only danger comes from
Lynette and her paranoia or that maybe
she's like gone crazy like gone off the
deep end so like most of Grady
hendricks's books this is just a really
really entertaining book and it pretty
much hits the gas from the first page
and it never lets up and it just kind of
just builds up to this really big like
violent fast-paced climax I mean I had a
blast reading this I just couldn't wait
because like I said I read it on my
phone like on my lunch hour and stuff
and I just couldn't wait to get back to
it because I was like oh [__] man what's
gonna happen next you know what I mean
and I got invested in in the story
straight away like especially Lynette's
character who is clearly very damaged uh
but she's also really interesting and
she is she's a sympathetic character and
she's a very realistic character like
she does a lot of stuff that's unlikable
but she's still relatable because
she kind of Acts the way a lot of real
people in her situation would act so you
can kind of like believe a lot of the
things that she does even if they're not
great you know what I mean
um now if I had any criticisms about it
I would note that a lot of the other
characters like the other final girls
are not sketched out all this they're
like a little bit shallow which I guess
isn't too surprising because there are
like a lot of characters and there it's
all from Lynette's point of view anyway
and I will say that some of the third
act twists because there are a lot of
them I think they kind of came and went
a little too quickly for me to get a
good handle on them like I had to kind
of like catch up you know what I mean
um but other than that I kind of feel
like I think this book was just as fun
as like all of his other ones now I will
say that even though slashers aren't
really my favorite horror subgenre
but this one uh it basically just took
the concept of a slasher and it kind of
deepened it or expanded it because it
focuses more on not so much the slasher
aspect like a slasher movie aspect but
it focuses more on what would happen in
the aftermath and what effect the trauma
would have like on the survivors of
these horrific crimes you know where
it's like you saw your all of your
friends massacred at the summer camp or
whatever like what would happen to those
women afterward like after everything
had died down so I thought that was like
a really cool thing to explore
um and also the fact that they had like
some measure of celebrity too so that
was kind of interesting but the thing
about it it's like so it does all that
but then it's also kind of a slasher in
its own right because the final girls
are kind of getting hunted down one by
one not in a classic slasher fashion but
still kind of like in a murder mystery
kind of fashion so I will say it's this
kind of smart I don't want to go so far
as to say satire is not exactly a satire
but it's kind of satirical and it also
serves as like a really good example of
the thing that it's kind of satirizing
if that makes any sense so if you liked
Grady hendricks's other stuff um I can't
imagine why you wouldn't like this one
as well now I will say I still think
that my best friend my best friend's
exorcism is my favorite book of his that
of out of all the ones that I've read so
far
um but this one is like is definitely
worth reading
um it's a page Turner for sure uh has
lots of Gore if you're into that like
lots of Gore lots of violence
um you know kind of a fairly high body
count but it also has kind of an
interesting examination in it of
a little bit like the culture's
relationship with slasher movies in
particular and violence against women in
general like it kind of subtly alludes
to maybe our propensity to find
entertainment value in like really
gruesome murders especially like if the
victim is like a beautiful woman so it
kind of goes a little bit and I don't
want to go too far in that direction
because people will be like oh it's like
a message book and it's not like that
like it's not heavy-handed or anything
but there are like some kind of
fascinating sort of Concepts in there to
dive into if you want to but it's not
like super in your face about it
um I'm actually curious to see uh I
really do kind of hope that they make
the TV series now because I'm curious to
see how this translates like to a visual
medium because I think this concept was
really tailor-made for that and I even
like saw some reviews on Goodreads where
they said where they didn't love the
book but they said this would make a
better movie than a book maybe and I
don't know if I agree with that exactly
but I think this actually would make a
really really good movie or a really
good series because it's really kind of
set up for that but um you know even if
they never make the TV series which they
might not the book is pretty great in
its own right so you know if you really
like that kind of just like entertaining
fun kind of gory uh you know slasher
type stuff like I said it's satirical a
little bit but it's not like super funny
it's not like over the top satirical but
it still has that edge to it and it's
kind of meta and uh like I said if
you're a horror fan especially if you're
willing to slashers from the 70s and 80s
you'll have a good time like kind of
picking out all the references that he
went because he I mean Grady Hendricks
like I said he wrote a book about
paperback horror from the 70s and 80s
and he knows a lot about that so he
really kind of like Marshals a lot of
his uh horror trivia like in this book
so it's kind of fun like picking all
that stuff out so yeah I would recommend
it if you if it sounds at all intriguing
to you so that will do it for this tomes
of Terror hope you enjoyed it please
like share and leave a comment if you
have read this book or if it sounds
interesting to you and I will see you
guys again on the next one bye
thank you
[Music]